E aí
oi oi
Oi e aí você que está assistindo Tex
você gosta de uma boa série uma boa
série de televisão
Tá bom eu gosto quando eu falo com meus
amigos sobre esse assunto todos eles
dizem que eu sou viciado e realmente eu
sou viciado desde pequeno eu lembro lá
nos anos 80 que eu curtia muito esperar
o a profissão perigo não sei se você
lembra uma cá ver lembra vou marcar e
fez eu amar séries e esperar sempre que
sempre o próximo episódio sempre a
próxima ação sempre o que que
aconteceria isso sempre me motivou e
talvez vocês também esse motivo muitos
de vocês gostam de séries e quem de
vocês quem nunca quem nunca é chegou e
chegou naquela sexta-feira e chegou e
esse puxa eu vou é emendar eu vou e
seguir com a minha série eu vou a minha
série favorita eu vou assistir ali
inteira vou curtir um monte vou curtir a
temporada toda até final de semana
Netflix vai ver se eu tô morto até
porque ele vai perguntar Thais Vivo ou
tu não tá
é bom talvez uma quinta-feira eu tenho
amigo te convidou para comer pizza e
você chegou assim não hoje não não tô
muito Afe sabe tô um pouco doente eu vou
cansado na verdade que estava rolando
era aquele próximo episódio da sua série
favorita e você queria curtir muito ele
e que nem uma pizza iria comprar
é mas sabe que uma coisa muito massa eu
que realmente sou o tal do amante de
séries Se tem uma coisa legal é você
encontrar uma pessoa apaixonada pela
mesma série que você você tá andando no
meio da rua e de repente você encontra
aquela pessoa falando a palavra friend
esse pera aí pera aí desculpa te
interromper mais tava falando o quê
mesmo sobre frente
e a gente quando a gente vê a série
favorita e a gente encontra aquela
pessoa a gente curte demais a gente se
empolga e é isso que faz a gente se
motivar Eis que faz esse mundo da série
se sensacional bom é tão sensacional e a
gente pergunta por que que eu gosto é
porque a gente gosta tanto de sede
porque a maioria de vocês que ele está
nos assistindo gosta de séries eu penso
que um dos motivos maiores desse prazer
que a gente tem assistir é justamente a
nossa ansiedade é um cliffhanger que
momento em que a gente fica pensando
claramente e o que que tá acontecendo o
que que vai acontecer daqui para frente
é aquele momento que o Netflix criou uma
maneira Sobrenatural para gente que é o
próximo episódio Não suporto ver aquele
botãozinho sem clicar à beira do
precipício eu estou esperando o que que
vai acontecer e mexe com a nossa
sociedade México aquilo que é mais
primitivo do ser humano no sentido de
saber o que que vai acontecer eu acho
que as férias mexem com isso a nossa
mente mexe com esse pensamento bom
Oi e aí quando a gente pensa sobre isso
é muitas vezes aquele próximo episódio
Nem é tanto assim a expectativa nem é
tanto daquela daquela forma mas mesmo
assim ela mexe com a gente por outras
vezes sim mexe isso tem pouco a ver com
a nossa realidade a realidade da série
tem muito a ver com nós e você vai ver
ao longo dessa minha palestra que a
gente na verdade tem essa relação com o
mundo das Artes com o mundo da e a
séries falam muito sobre nós e ansiedade
fala pesado com a gente fala quando a
gente quer esperar o que que vai
acontecer daqui para frente que que vai
ser no meu futuro e aí é muitas vezes as
expectativas são tão diferentes da
realidade não é mesmo bom a gente pode
ir pensar que nem só de que rende Às
vezes uma série ela vive de um outro
personagem muito importante e ele se
chama o vilão bom vilão Esse sim é
aquele que nos faz amar e que nos faz
odiar eu odeio vilões eu já amei velozes
Eu já mudei de opinião eu já já pensei
que vilões era o personagem principal e
repetição ela então tudo
o e nas nossas vidas é meio que assim
também a gente muitas vezes tem aquele
aquele vilão que a nosso príncipe
encantado talvez a nossa rainha outras
vezes a gente mesmo o próprio personagem
principal e o vilão e a gente não se
conforma e nossa vida do mesmo jeito a
gente muitas vezes a gente pode ser o
nosso próprio violão
e não tem aquelas vez que tu tá
assistindo a série e ela e tu tá com teu
personagem preferido o teu protagonista
indo para um abismo e tu disse para
freia desacelera amigo não faz assim e a
gente disse Por favor a gente conversa
você nunca conversou com o teu
personagem preferido na Série A o
viciado em série conversa bom e aí a
gente conversa com ele disse para com
tudo e a gente na verdade é assim
e muitas vezes a gente fez a bota nós
mesmos a gente busca a nossa própria
auto-sabotagem a gente Escuta as vozes
que desacelera para e a gente não para
EA gente vai rumos aos nossos abismos
aos nossos problemas vilões agora assim
ó quando um junto vilão com cliffhangers
o abismo e eles têm um poder para fazer
isso aí surgiu um outro nome da série
que a gente costuma falar que são os
produtos bom ter um plot Twist ele é
algo que nos quebra o pote Twist ficou
pronto Steven para a gente viram retirar
toda a série para fazer uma analogia
Você já viu um ciclone bomba sabe como é
que funciona igual porque ele faz
Ciclone bomba dentro da série ao toque
Twist puxa o tapete do personagem
principal faz a revira-volta acontecer
faz as coisas mudarem completamente a
coisa estava indo no rumo você estava
pensando agora cima o personagem vai
conseguir conquistar a Amada E aí muda
tudo
a prostituição os momentos fundamentais
da série que o vilão faz a sua arte e
que o personagem faz a sua o seu erro e
as coisas mudam completamente eles podem
ser vilões externos que fazem ou às
vezes você mesmo faz o teu plot Twist
E você tá vendo que eu tô falando um
paralelo entre a minha vida e as séries
e 21 anos atrás eu passei por um plot
Twist
o Spot triste fez eu pensar errei viver
e repensar o meu modo de viver
hoje com 27 anos eu fui diagnosticado
com câncer bom quando você é
diagnosticado com câncer 21 anos atrás
talvez mesmo hoje ainda nesses tempos a
gente quando tem esse diagnóstico não é
nada fácil encarar Lu 21 anos atrás para
mim foi Tenebroso porque a situações
eram diferentes
Oi e aquele pote triste veio de uma
forma totalmente um ciclo de bomba na
minha vida eu era recém-casado nós
estávamos naquele sonho de casal novo
tentando conquistar nossas vidas
buscando as oportunidades que ela talvez
até então a vida não tinha nos oferecido
e a gente corre atrás daquele mundo de
oportunidades de repente eu tive que
parar e eu tive que buscar cuidar da
minha vida
o Sport Twister faz eu te conhecer
conhecer um vilão que até então para mim
era quase desconhecido um vilão que
talvez tem tem destruído tantas vidas
esse vilão que é o câncer ele Talvez tem
uma tem ter levado à morte muito mais
pessoas com certeza do que o demogorgon
do do stranger things e ele tem levado o
centenas e milhares de vidas ao redor de
todo mundo hoje só para você ter uma
ideia são 18 milhões de pessoas em 2020
com a possibilidade de encarar e tem que
encarar um câncer dessas 18 milhões 10
milhões de pessoas vão encontrar o final
da sua série A Série ser cancelada a sua
série vai encontrar o último episódio a
morte 10 milhões de pessoas só no Brasil
são 625.000 estimados pela 2020 e se
você pensar nesse 125.000 talvez 500 mil
pessoas vão perder suas vidas por causa
do Câncer Olha só loucura se você que
está me Assistindo e você que tá ouvindo
hoje eu falar agora sobre esse plot
Twist dessa própria palestra você pode
e aqui de cada oito pessoas que estão me
assistindo oito homens que estão me
assistindo assistindo um pode estar com
a possibilidade de ter câncer nesse ano
há 11 mulheres dentre 11 mulheres uma
pode estar com câncer bom as
estatísticas são terríveis Elas mostram
para nós e que realmente o câncer ainda
é a mesmo Século 21 ele ainda é uma a
segunda maior causa de mortes do mundo
Ah mas eu não quero só ficar das
especificações e nas alarmes as eu quero
falar para você que se você levar a
sério agora algo que eu tenho para te
falar é quarenta por cento das pessoas
que poderiam ter seus o seu diagnósticos
de câncer elas podem não ter essa
notícia ruim essa notícia ruim é baseada
através de uma palavra muito simples que
talvez seja difícil para gente tomar são
que erra prevenção e eu digo para vocês
que prevenção ela envolve todo o nosso
contexto de vida seja mental seja físico
seja espiritual e eu preciso buscar as
prevenções Para poderem realmente
eliminar quarenta trinta por cento das
pessoas que estão indo para a mesma
estrada numa velocidade terrível e
encontrando o diagnóstico do Câncer EA
queria deixar essa mensagem para você
para que você hoje pudesse desacelerar
para que você pudesse quem sabe parar ou
pouco o seu o seu ritmo e você pudesse
dizer o que que eu preciso fazer para
cuidar da minha vida e para não ter que
viver o mesmo dia que nosso que eu tive
que viver
Oi eu queria te falar que você pode sim
através de hábitos alimentares saudáveis
através de atividades físicas regulares
e através de hábitos mentais e em buscar
realmente a inteligência emocional
buscar a saúde emocional e saúde mental
você pode sim encontrar saúde e você
pode fugir sim de uma situação terrível
com essa
e a gente muitas vezes a nossa pressa
Nossa velocidade a nossa pressa sabe que
que ela precisa levar ela não dizem
precisa levar para gente parar tudo
porque muitas vezes a doença faz a gente
parar o câncer fez eu parar o câncer
desacelerou minha vida mas você pode
desacelerar antes você pode parar antes
e esse parar antes significa Talvez o
parar tudo a nossa pressa Talvez seja
dizer eu quero parar tudo e eu preciso
parar tudo para cuidar da minha vida
leva a sério isso busca é antes de
qualquer doença parar a sua vida buscar
realmente com que as coisas aconteçam
mais fácil a gente se recuperar depois
de um câncer o tratamento é terrível as
coisas são livres e a gente precisa
vencer isso todo e eu tive que vencer e
tive que lutar para poder lutar contra
todas as sequelas E aí eu sou grato a
todos os fisioterapeutas todos os
médicos todos os nutricionistas as
pessoas que ao longo de 21 anos me
ajudaram a me recuperar eu quero não
fazer um parente aqui mais fazer uma
ênfase aos profissionais de educação
física as pessoas que cuidam da Saúde da
gente você pode sair aqui amanhã e para
a academia dizer ó e vou fazer a
primeira são minha Vamos fazer uma
atividade física aos Heróis da Fé
pessoas que me ensinaram a busca da
espiritualidade de mostrar um caminho
diferente que eu pudesse buscar uma
saúde mental e espiritual
hoje eu quero falar pra vocês
rapidamente quando a gente pensa é que
os Episódios das séries nos levam a
crises a gente também passa por crises
essas crises podem nos levar a situações
de dificuldade eu queria dizer uma coisa
para vocês passa vai passar é temporário
leva a sério isso a gente precisa muitas
vezes nesse nesses momentos apenas o
crescer um abraço e pronto a outra coisa
importante que a gente precisa entender
nos Episódios de crises episódio da
série é que a gente se fortalece a gente
encontra fortalecimento Quem viu
a arma start in Game of Thrones e
Desculpa quem vai reclamar uma meu vai
falar spoiler de Game of Thrones hora
que quem é viciado em série com certeza
já já assistiu e não vai ficar bravo com
isso olhos quem assistiu olhar o estoque
ninguém of Thrones e um forte viu ela
perdeu o seu pai no primeiro nos
primeiros a primeira temporada E aí ela
segue uma trajetória um rumo um caminho
totalmente diferente totalmente
inusitados primeiro de Vingança de raiva
e depois ela começa a buscar sabedoria
busca conhecimento e ela começa a viver
uma nova oportunidade ao estoque se
cresce é fortalece buscar suas raízes e
a gente a profunda raízes quando vento
forte quando os plot twists Vem quando o
ciclone surge nas nossas vidas
bom e quando a gente se for tá gente
busca às raízes e a gente a profunda
raízes a gente cresce e quando a gente
cresce os problemas não são mais tão
grandes quanto a gente imaginava a gente
consegue ficar maior do que os problemas
E aí quando é bom a gente vê na nossa
série os nossos personagens preferidos
crescendo arya Stark começa a crescer
durante a série histórica que começa a
ser aquela pessoa que tudo isso é essa
que eu quero esse tantos personagens
nossas séries favoritas nos fazem pensar
que legal tá crescendo é isso que eu
gosto é isso que faz a série
sensacionais
Oi e aí quando vai estar que está lá no
momento dela de crescimento e de
fortalecimento e assim que é a tua vida
e a minha vida também e que a gente
passa a entender que o nosso sede São
episódios de vida um atrás do outro
quando a gente começa a viver dessa
forma a gente encontra algo muito
fundamental que é o Nosso propósito por
que que eu existo por que que eu estou
aqui por quê que eu estou vivendo esse
momento
E aí só que tem a sua trajetória ela
chega em Game of Thrones ela naquele
momento em que a gente via que o
westeros ia ser destruída não era mais
pela briga dos reis dos reis mas é o dos
Reis dos sete reinos Mas é porque existe
um rei da noite um senhor do gelo que
queria destruir todo westeros toda toda
aquele aquele reino
a gente nunca imaginava que arya Stark
ela iria ser a protagonista naquele
momento cumprindo o seu propósito
e eu não sei você aí que tá nem
assistindo
o que você se acha uma arma start
pequena talvez em defesa e segura com
uma espada pequenininha com algo que
você não consiga vencer Mas eu queria te
dizer que
e você pode ser protagonista da sua
história assim e quando você a
protagonista que você impacta contra o
propósito e o propósito das outras
quando você cria nas pessoas o senso de
propósito Eu só posso dizer uma coisa
para você você traz felicidade para toda
o seu meio para todo lugar que você vive
e quando você cumprir seu propósito é
isso que acontece é
[Música]
E aí
e é isso você encontra o seu propósito
você encontra a felicidade você faz com
que os outros que estão ao redor também
encontra felicidade isso é sensacional
quando você chega no centro de cococi
trás isso para a vida das pessoas bom
pessoal quando a gente encontra o
propósito a gente parece que precisa
encontrar também aquele que nos motiva
aquilo que nos leva a lei que é o nosso
legado que nos leva além e muitas vezes
nosso legado Depende de encontrar algo
que é superior a nosso protagonismo e
são os nossos heróis eu quero te motivar
a buscar o seu herói eu não tô te
dizendo para buscar sistemas métodos
formas eu tô te dizendo para você buscar
e conhecer o seu herói
e quando você buscar o seu herói você
vai encontrar o seu legado e você vai
encontrar o impacto que você pode ter na
tua vida e na vida dos outros conhecer o
Olho no Olho conhecer mesmo e quanto
mais a gente conhece mais a gente confia
e quando eu falo de confiança
e quando eu estava
Tô terminando o meu o meu tratamento e
minha esposa a gente se olhou isso a
gente precisa encontrar esse legado a
gente precisa continuar a nossa
trajetória e fazia tanta falta daqui a
pouco do nada a gente sente falta de
formar uma família de verdade que uma
como filho uma filha
e deixa de pessoa a gente tá sozinha a
gente precisa disso e quando a gente
entendeu a gente pensou que era hora da
gente buscar
Ah e eu não podia ter filhos por conta
do tratamento a gastei com ela que tinha
tido era séria e a espermatogênese havia
sido queimado por causa de radioterapia
E por aí vai e a gente ficou durante
anos buscando essa esse tratamento e
buscando o recorrer o herói buscando
essa confiança que a gente tinha na
nossa herói a gente buscou amigos que
também orava por nós e pediram para que
isso mudasse e de repente as coisas
começaram a mudar de verdade e um
pouquinho de espermatozoides começou a
surgir a possibilidade de ter um filho
começou a ter a surgir EA gente começou
acreditar naquilo E aí
em pouco tempo depois Três anos depois a
minha esposa estava no médico e e ela
conversando com a médica a médica disse
para ela olha tá começando a ter uma
esperança mas é muito pouco e quem sabe
você não faz uma inseminação artificial
e a Dani ela disse que ela falou isso
para médica ela disse olha o Xande foi
um milagre ele podia ter morrido Porque
neste tempo de agora vencer um câncer e
mas eu acho que o câncer não é o único
milagre ele é muito maior do que isso e
é só o começo essa vitória dele então a
nossa filha vai ser também um milagre
há quatro anos depois do ter recebido o
diagnóstico de um câncer eu recebi um
outro resultado de um laboratório não
era mais uma notícia ruim era uma
notícia maravilhosa eu tinha a minha
filha Ana Clara
tá pronta para lixo
há 16 anos depois a gente está junto de
seis anos depois a gente vê que os
pequenos milagres da vida são aqui nos
morros aqui nos modificam Os Pequenos
milagres da vida são impressionantes
para nós e quem a gente pode ver quando
a gente pensa eu preciso de um plot
Twist para fazer sentido na minha vida
eu só quero te dizer que eu aprendi uma
coisa muito importante são os pequenos
milagres da vida que nos faz a diferença
não sou um privilegiado por ter passado
por um plot Twist na verdade eu me sinto
privilegiado porque eu aprendi uma lição
a viver os milagres da vida independente
de ser doença ou ser saúde e dependente
da dor independente da Alegria do Prazer
independente de qualquer coisa O mais
importante é você viver claramente os
milagres da vida todos os dias
bom e quando a gente vive os milagres da
vida todos os dias a gente começa a
entender de que sim é muito mais
importante eu encontrar o meu equilíbrio
espiritual o meu equilíbrio mental e o
equilíbrio físico e eu e coragem de você
a buscar isso busque a força na sua no
seu corpo a saúde do seu corpo música
que atualmente está saudável e feliz e
busque a fé Muito obrigado a
E aí
[Música]